man the arkham knight review is my best
work yet it's going to be amazing
articles is it done is it what done
finished complete it over oh god no no
no no no well but I think you could do
something so you don't leave your
subscribers completely hanging I don't
know I guess there's something I could
try well what are you waiting for do it
alright
do you just wear that under your clothes
all the time yeah and you don't
[Music]
I had to use this costume for something
hey there people of the Internet
welcome to part 1 as the intro explained
the arkham knight review is absolutely
going to be worth the wait but that
still means there's going to be a wait
so in the meantime while I'm working on
that I'll have something else for you
guys to watch in this can be multiple
videos I just think like every time I
look at my uploads and see that it's
been a while like a month or two since
the last thing I put out I let's do a
little bit guilty for keeping you
hanging for so long so here's something
that's easier to make that I can put out
a whole bunch of and I think I mean it
has spider-man in the title so I think
you guys will like it
you know because because that's fun
review sure got a lot of views you know
anyway uh I love this game I think it's
objectively the best or at least one of
the best spider-man games and the reason
for that being that it's the only one in
which he does not diffuse an explosive
device anyway I won't be bringing that
up at any point because push did we beat
that horse
so yeah let's play one last little note
is that I won't be talking over the
cutscene because this game's story is
really good and also this game doesn't
have subtitles because ps2 so I'm gonna
try not get in the way of that and
undermine the story by talking over it
constantly so expect me to be a little
bit silent for the first few minutes
alright let's get into it
yep cutscenes I like the loading screens
except they spoil the cutscene sometimes
how it all began which of course
nonsense like this few months ago I
reunited with my childhood friend Eddie
Brock what is that it's power
inheritance Eddie's dad and my dad work
together before they died all I want to
do is try to help them they take this
cute away from dad and I was going to
take back
I thought I knew I could finish what he
started I felt good great more than
myself it didn't last
I don't know the suitors become what it
is done to me but I am super spider
power tonight I couldn't control it
so I don't think anyone could ever hope
to but when Eddie found out what I had
done it really was
well he was pretty angry
our fathers died and we're right into it
hey you ever notice how every time you
see venom or like older characters like
that or I was kind of hunched over a lot
because when venom stands like perfectly
straight he's like something like nine
feet tall all right so uh when we get
straight into it with like immediately a
boss fight was one of the coolest
spider-man villains gotta get any
off-campus before somebody I'm gonna
talk over his cutscene coos it's not
really a dialogue and I need to deal to
talk during just let's play where I talk
hey this is the fourth time I recorded
this because my software hates recording
a PSP game for some reason I love the
way the cutscenes are done in this game
just because it's like the first time
anyone's done this motion comic style
without it looking really stupid like
the live-action Hulk movie from 2003
I also think this whole segment like the
way it's played off here despite just
seems a little bit cooler in the game as
opposed to the sama have to put it down
except for the part where spider-man
hits Eddie in the face with like a truck
tire and birth questions out of his head
that's pretty cool a fun fact you can
choose this fight by tricking him into
walking into the electricity let's see
if we can do it yeah there we go
well you're getting your money's worth I
bet all of you knew that trick looks
like in case you didn't there you go
I need it it's not done get it back it's
really not done I can't go swinging
around in my nerd clothes I just have to
finish stitching up a hole in the butt
and then I'll give it back to you
I can explain the hole in the butt by
the way please don't come by the place
in about half an hour and I'll have it
ready for you all right I'm going to run
by home and grab my web-shooters ok
tutorial fun day time for a little
workout you know is the kid I always
kind of want to rush through this
segment because I didn't want anyone to
see Peter Parker hopping around without
his mask on like I always overthink
things and I immediately jumped kind of
freaked out as soon as there's a segment
like this so the most things I do it's
me the amazing jumping man the
spectacular leaping dude it's the
sensational talking to myself guy all
right quit being so easily amused you
know I know how you feel buddy I'm
talking to myself here too yeah yeah so
you may notice I don't have a yeah I
don't have a co-host for this and I
realize that's because I'm talking over
this one too because why not I know what
none of my friends really give enough of
a [ __ ] about comic books to like even
have a conversation about this stuff
so I'm just going to be talking at you
because there's pretty much the same
experience like I'm cutting out the
middleman if I had someone else here
like David or tile or whoever from my
dueño other pretty much plays it would
mostly just be me saying yeah that
reminds me of this one thing from issue
whatever whatever where this thing
happens and then they would just go yeah
mmhmm yeah that sounds cool so whatever
I'm just gonna talk at no.1 and
hopefully that's entertaining enough
that we can make a video out of it boy
you know you could tell Brian Michael
Bendis wrote this game because there's a
lot of scenes where spider-man's doing
stuff without his costume and that seems
to be one of Bendis is like favorite
things ever having him do things outside
of his costume stitching those is hard I
know from personal experience Jeremy
you've done with my foot
oh yeah there's an idiot causing trouble
a few blocks from here I need to
skedaddle
cool pose but I should use after the
video thumbnail or something unless I
come home for something weird for cooler
all right let's go do more tutorial
stuff I never knew your name was Herman
well you are kind of in my neighborhood
Herman you came to the wrong friendly
neighborhood [ __ ] I'll go easy on you
this time only use my eldest I would be
top calorie I'm Julia don't wonder you
guys head back here pretty much the only
way to stop him alright cool about this
hand I think the original shockers like
gauntlets or they vibrate too hard for
the betterment web to even work on them
the ultimate universe kind of plays off
shocker as a joke but I think you can be
cool if done right like in the alt the
original universe
good old predictable heard year round
here's one of the few scenes I think is
actually better in the comics because
spider-man makes a yo mama joke I am you
guys walking cliche seriously
good for you what come on guys leave the
lady alone I really like the combat in
this one because just the way spider-man
kind of propels off of stuff it reminds
me of the way Mark Bagley draws the
fight team okay so in in the books away
badly all NPCs draw spider-man fighting
people with that there's this sort of
like motion in the way swinging or
moving or punching it always looks like
he's just bounced off of something
he's always got this sort of propulsion
behind him so the game created a sort of
combat system where you're just
constantly like bouncing off of every
object in the environment to get
momentum and I think that looks cool and
I just I don't know it makes you have to
like think about where where you are a
little bit more than most games because
it's usually better to go try and get
near a wall because that helps you like
use your force like to your advantage
because spider-man can hit even harder
fees like launching off of something and
using his own weight so when you're
fighting someone in like let's say like
an empty parking lot or like that field
over there there's not really a kind of
force behind your punches because
ultimate spider-man is a lot weaker than
the original one the original one can
like punch someone's head off you know
but like like giving them a slice
backhand
I there's still dialogue in this game
that I've never heard before because
there's so much like clever stuff
written for this yo-yo sighting
Johnny Storm of the world-famous
Fantastic Four what on earth are you
doing in Queens
a lot I can't be in Queens I have to be
here but you go save the world I got a
better idea will you say a quick race
around Queens what is it you think just
because you can fly in a streak of fire
oh you can beat me I do believe that
what I'm saying
and I've got two words for you bring it
on one of my favorite like bromances and
comic books has always been a mentor to
spider-man it's never really shown a lot
anywhere outside of the book maybe this
game and then the ps1 game from 2000 but
they're like absolutely best friends
because they are really close in age and
they have similar senses of humor and
that's like that's something that I want
to see in a movie one day you know God
willing big finally give up the [ __ ]
rights for the fantastic four movies or
Marvel
oh wait dark Hawk and I can't he glide
it's I don't know how I don't know if
that's necessarily an insult this race
used to be so hard when I was a little
kid that always had my dad or my uncle
or someone do it for me because I
stopped disciplining but now I can like
practically do it in my sleep I can't
tell if the fishes I've been playing
this game so long or that the controls
are just actually that good but this
game feels so smooth even he's playing
it's 12 years after it came out the
animations are also really cool for the
way spider-man swings like just when he
gets a lot of momentum and then just
kind of like starts laying around in the
air you look almost like a like an
elegant dancer alright so we have such a
lead I can just sit up here and talk
about stuff I remember I read an article
once around the time the Fox Fantastic
Four movie came out that said that they
cancelled the comic book Fantastic Four
because Marvel was upset about Michael B
Jordan being cast is Johnny Storm even
though like the book was like Ewing
super poor and sale oh man you're better
than I thought now I owe you
yeah whatever you ever want to race
again look me up I'm usually hanging out
by the Baxter building
alright thanks Danny Phantom ok while
all these pop-ups are on-screen I'll
keep talking so yeah there's also good
god there's so many of them I like I
remember they kept saying that I guess
they canceled the Fantastic Four books
because they're racist and they they
hate black people and Marvel would never
allow one of their white characters to
be cast by a black actor even though
that happens all the time even sometimes
their own decisions so like eventually
uh even though that article came out and
said that's the reason that Fantastic
Four got the kibosh like in reality the
only Fantastic Four member
that actively still being used as a
character of Human Torch like he's a
member of the uncanny Avengers now while
his Ben Grimm is off doing like whatever
I guess he's like been relegated to
cameo appearances and you know to in
read I think are like off fixing
multiple universes after the Secret Wars
thing I don't know I didn't like I was
actually one of the stupid people who
was like kind of excited for that
Fantastic Four movie I was like hey look
it's like Cronenberg's Fantastic Four
it's all kinds of weird body horror and
a superhero horror movie hasn't been
done yet it's like a weird idea
I don't know Fantastic Four is
necessarily the best I just like the
characters to use for that but it was an
interesting concept and it didn't work
out
ow well off apparently spider senses
fails me once again all right as soon as
I smack these Schmucks
into next week I guess that'll be at the
end of part 1 so let me know you guys
think about this series is this
something that took God I didn't think I
hit the car that hard oh thank you he'll
pick up um let me know what you guys
think about this series or just like me
kind of chatting at nothing like is this
something you'd be interested in seeing
more of I'm definitely going to do this
whole game but I don't know if I'll do
any game after it unless of course this
is something you guys find interesting
but um yeah oh yeah I forgot this one
has fall damage so if there's anything
you want me specifically to talk about
those feel free to like bring that up
and be like hey you know here be a cool
talking point or what's your opinion of
X comics bookie things and all kind of
put together a list and just sort of
ramble about it in the off moment
because as with every spider-man game
there's like the moments where you're
allowed to just feel swinging around
doing nothing so you know in killing
time I'll answer questions and I always
like getting like
fan interactivity in there because I
just answering questions or you know
being nice and telling a little bit more
about myself to you guys like that's
some of my favorite stuff about this I
love having an audience and I love
sharing things like my thoughts or you
know stuff like that so don't be shy ask
me questions or tell me what you think
just something so yeah I figured out
that if I record anything longer than
life Wow
that was 20 minutes for a part my Game
Capture is going to start like freaking
out and exploding because it doesn't
like recording ps2 game let's get you to
the hospital ma'am where are you getting
attacked in front of is this the sanctum
sanctorum can I find that machine you
know what that would be a goal if you'll
find that they probably put it in there
so ah who is this this this lady gets to
the pits to the hospital you have a go
yeah how much you help
man if only like there was some kind of
service in in the in the city like some
kind of like truck that'll drive to
people who are in need and then pick
them up and it'll have like a hospital
room in the back and then they could
like take care of people while they're
driving them back or Hospital if only
those were a thing that existed look the
librarian embassy let's go pee on the
side of it Let's Plays are cheap and
easy
[Music]